nous sommes mandatés par personne je ne
semble pas les défenseurs de monsieur
bédard a donc tout ce que j'entends à
côté sur ce sujet je tiens à mettre à
poil mois pour dire voulait clarifier
exactement votre position nous n'irons
pas à la commission denquête mercredi
matin nous l'avons décidé d'un commun
accord journée parlementaire avec
rihanna richer qui a été présent tout le
temps est ce le cas également d' arnaud
de belenet ou de thani mohamed soilihi
est ce que tous nous boycotter s'entend
pas là aujourd'hui at any two journées
parlementaires n'ont pas évoqué avec lui
mais nous avons dit que nous n'irions
pas voilà à la réserve au mieux des
vêtements très bien mais les autres je
ne pense pas qu'il soit là non plus une
sono ni l'un ni l'autre
bon donc ils ne seront pas là mais pour
des raisons autres il s'agit pas
forcément d'un boycott se sont pas
exprimés je tiens le a alors appelé ici
non nous pensons aujourd'hui que dans ce
que je ne trouve l'avant appelé la
saison 2 de la sphère benalla l'épisode
l'épisode 2 va être surmédiatisée je me
tâte izay par la volonté de la
commission qui entend aujourd'hui autour
de la sphère benalla poursuivre ses
investigations selon elle a le droit et
ce qu'elle fera mais elle le fait dans
une forme de tintamarre médiatique qui
n'est pas sans rappeler j'allais dire
une forme qui allait dire non pas
d'atteinte
mais ce que nous savons c'est que la
commission en fin de compte nous aurons
le sentiment qu'elle se soucie peu
d'alexandre canada qu'elle se soucie
plutôt de porter atteinte à la fois au
gouvernement et au chef de l'état
voilà c'est la raison pour laquelle sur
cette affaire benalla les trois plus
proches collaborateurs du chef de l'état
ont été entendus ils ont donné la
réponse ils ont dit la vérité
maintenant je le sens j'ai le sentiment
que nous savons pratiquement tous que
tout a été dit que les réponses ont été
apportées mais on continue à faire
croire qu'il aurait des zones floues
est ce la raison pour laquelle devancé
j'allais dire cet excès de zèle qui
n'est pas pour nous protéger de qui que
ce soit
nous préférons nous tenir à l'écart
qu'est ce que pour vous la commission
denquête cherche à faire en auditionnant
alexandre benalla vous jugez que c'est
utile que c'est inutile a manifestement
est ce que pour vous c'est un coup aussi
médiatique
je pense que aujourd'hui la commission
va auditionner quelqu'un qui est sous le
coup d'une mise en examen judiciaire que
la justice doit poursuivre en toute
sérénité
et nous souhaitons que justice fait la
vérité sur les événements du 1er mai ce
que le sénat cherche aujourd'hui c'est
cherchent à savoir s'il y eu des
dysfonctionnements dans la chaîne de
commandement autour de trois questions
port d'armes missions de police voiture
et gyrophares ces trois questions
tournent en boucle et les réponses ont
été apportées
nous pensons aujourd'hui que voilà on
essaye d'en faire un peu trop à notre
notre gré et que nous avec une préférons
ne pas être présent une toute dernière
question est ce que vous allez boycotter
le reste des travaux de la commission
denquête où c'est seulement pour cette
audition
on va voir comment on va d'abord voir
comment se déroule ce mercredi
moi je pense qu'après l'émission du
mercredi la tension va beaucoup retombée
parce que le sénat aurait eu son jour de
gloire ce que nous pensons aussi c'est
que peut-être le sénat en ce mois de
septembre à d'autres priorités
si les priorités budgétaires il ya le
demain le plan santé qui va être revu
mais parle par le chef de l'état il ya
le plan pauvreté il ya la loi et galim
qui vient ici à la réforme de la justice
semble que le sénat a d'autres sujets de
préoccupation urgent que de faire la
lumière
bien entendu c'est son droit de la
rechercher je pense qu'elle a déjà été
fait